hola que tal buenas noches tal vez no se
ve está a oscuras detrás mío pero la
ciudad empieza a encenderse hace unos
minutos empezó a encenderse con festejos
apenas terminó el partido después de
unos minutos de tenso silencio
explotaron los ruidos los bocinas a los
gritos todavía y bocinazos a lo lejos a
lo lejos tal vez no nos llegan a
escucharse aquí pero se escucha el ánimo
celebratorio es clave más allá de lo que
implica para argentina ver a esta
generación como bien decía la generación
de lionel messi en la que diría que uno
de los que quedan es lionel messi ángel
di maria no necesariamente todos los
jugadores a los jugadores más jóvenes
que se incorporaron no hace tanto a la
selección hay una cosa muy fuerte en
este en este contexto tan difícil para
argentina de hecho para el mundo de
pandemia pero en argentina también con
con una crisis económica persistente que
no deja de preocupar de ocupar y de
dificultar la vida de los argentinos
este momento de reencuentro con algo
agradable de una alegría como la que
puede dar el fútbol sobre todo con un
rival tradicional el gran rival como es
brasil en la casa de brasil en el
maracaná por supuesto es
muy importante en términos anímicos que
está siendo fuertemente celebrado si el
gol fue de ángel di maría pero tal vez
como vos mencionabas de algún modo es
una noche muy importante para los
leoneses no lionel messi que consigue
como decíamos un gran título un
importantísimo título finalmente con la
selección y el técnico lionel scaloni
que es un técnico que en argentina para
algunos había sido criticado había gente
que no le gustaba cómo jugaba como
armaba al equipo y él con su
organización del equipo fue dando
excelentes resultados sobre todo en el
campo defensivo una argentina que
lograba que no le convirtieran goles y
efectivamente otra vez con un estilo de
juego similar planteando un partido en
el que cuidó descuido del arco voy a
hablar con muy bien también con martínez
al arco que sacó por lo menos una pelota
sino dos muy complicadas logró sostener
ese gol de di maría que fue clave para
la victoria de argentina en río de
janeiro así que sí creo que siguen
fuerte los bocinazos me da me da lástima
que por ahí no se escuchen pero la
verdad que hay bastante intensidad en la
ciudad